me now larry kudlow former white house
economic advisor
larry explain what you mean by that
well look you know at the root of this
whole infrastructure plan which is
really
not about infrastructure it's kind of a
trojan horse for the green new deal
and a tax attack on american
corporations and a gigantic buildup of
the welfare state
with no work requirements but the
ideology here
is to enable washington bureaucrats and
central planners
to have the power in our economy and to
seek the demise of private companies
in free enterprise private economy
there's no question
when president biden talked about a new
paradigm
he's talking about a welfarist paradigm
he's talking about diminishing the
private economy
and the free enterprise and enabling
these central planners
it's a socialist model he wants to out
new deal the new deal
the trouble with the new deal was laura
at the end of eight or nine years
the unemployment rate was still 19
percent so we should remember that
so much for the welfare state and ditto
for the great society
but that's where president biden is
going and it is going to have grave
consequences
not only for the way this country is run
but also the economy itself
which with the opening the vaccines and
the reopening is booming
but this attack on companies large and
small will stop that next year could be
a much much
weaker year and the year after that much
worse so it's a tragedy
tragedy wrong direction absolutely
biden um never wastes an opportunity
larry to attack former president trump
or his policies
he did this again today watch
congress passed a tax cut of two
trillion dollars increasing the national
debt two trillion dollars
it didn't meet virtually any of the
predictions it would in terms
of growing the economy overwhelmingly
the benefits of that tax package went to
the wealthiest americans it was bad for
american competitors deeply unfair to
the middle class families
and wrong for our future
larry is any of this true
no there's not a single factoid in that
statement
um the tax cuts were the biggest
benefits
the increase in middle income wages and
family income and blue collar workers
and the increase in lower middle income
in fact laura it's the bottom 25
percentile the income still
that absolutely did the best not the top
in terms of wealth
and wages and incomes they did the best
the best performance
probably uh since the year 2000. now
look
president trump issued a statement today
i just want to read it because he hits
on a main factor here
president trump says that biden's
radical plan to
implement the largest tax hike in
american history
is a massive giveaway to china now what
president trump is saying here is that
raising
our corporate tax rate to 28 from 21
and you've got to add five points from
the states that's 33.
china is 25
we're also slapping on a 21
minimum tax for overseas income a 15
minimum tax here at home and a doubling
of the capital gains tax
where the integration of the corporate
tax actually would raise it to almost 70
percent
so what do you have you have a war
against investment
which means a war against new business
starts and technology advances
a war against productivity and a war
against
wages for the middle income people mind
you
you like to have good solid wages but in
order to have good solid wages
you have to have a successful business
and this plan
is going to tax successful businesses to
death it punishes success not rewards it
and it's just the absolute wrong
direction the wrong trump
right china is going to be a beneficiary
and competitors of our
overseas are going to be money's going
to fight the u.s
factories and jobs will flow out of the
u.s exactly
larry who's going to larry a friend of
mine tonight said
who the heck is going to invest in the
united states with this tax regime in
place and then you've got
millions of people pouring across our
border which going to lower wages
for the entry-level workers especially
hurt minority workers in the country
so that's happening at the same time
this is an unmitigated
disaster this bill complete disaster
yeah i think it's gonna it's gonna
really do damage to the economy if it
passes i don't know if it passes but it
might pass
51 vote reconciliation you know laura
from the very beginning
this so-called infrastructure that word
is very popular
it's a trojan horse phony a trojan horse
to reverse the trump tax cuts
a trojan horse who uh to uh put in the
green
new deal and a trojan horse for a
remarkable expansion of the welfare
state
with no work requirements this is an
ideological battle
from the far far left all right larry we
got a roll thank you so much